the Joe Rogan experience well the Rick
Baker seen when he transforms into the
werewolf in the chicks apartment we have
the in the nurse's apartment for the
first time and it he's like I'm [ __ ]
his back and it's like bright it's a
bright new apartment that's what makes
it weird ass and a hand strap [ __ ]
wild man to this damn weird just and
then he tried to kind of recreate like
the actual makeup style werewolf with
the Wolfman with Benicio del Toro yeah
but it just wasn't there the movie
wasn't there just wasn't wasn't quite
good enough but there's one [ __ ]
bad-ass scene where it becomes the
Wolfman when they're in the insane
asylum doing tests on them do you
remember that film I don't remember that
film that much I remember I don't I hate
saying things cuz this was my thought at
the time I remember watching it thinking
Benicio del Toro seems like he doesn't
want to be in this movie which is such a
stupid thing for me to say because I
don't know what the [ __ ] he wants I
think he's a brilliant actor and I
really like watching sighted but it just
had that feeling like I don't know what
it was and I I've talked to people
connected with that movie and I don't
think it was a great experience for
people for some reason maybe there was a
lot of meddling probably a lot of
meddling is that something that's a
difficult thing to manage or do you not
have to deal with that anymore I had to
deal with that a lot when I made the two
Halloween movies when steam company
because they're this gigantic franchise
well there was weird meddling it was
just like kind of psychotic meddling how
so just weird like like my phone was
ringing all the time when I'm on set
working and it'd be like we think it
should be this I'm like why you're
working yeah well if I did that then
everything we shot doesn't match and it
makes no sense it's just like doing coke
and just coming up like I don't know
it's just weird thoughts all the time
and but I mean a lot of times I don't
want to like name all these names of
people but I remember working on one
movie that never happened and whatever
was the number one movie that from that
weekend was exactly the notes I would
get for what we were working on
it didn't and I swear to God the time of
private parts and private parts was
number one I go I guarantee when I walk
in the office is gonna say can we get
Howard Stern in this movie and they did
no yes it didn't matter what it was if
it was Starship Troopers ago can we get
giant bugs in this movie suddenly wasn't
the Halloween movies is another movie
that never actually happened but and you
just like the little insanity the
uncreated executive that wants to be
creative is that is a classic story in
Hollywood I mean that's that's really
like a villain in a film about a movie
about a guy trying to make a movie yeah
I mean I thought we thought I will give
credit for things like I'm remember
working with Bob Weinstein and I always
thought like the first thing he would
say was spot-on like they they love
movies they have a good sense of movies
and he would say something you'd be like
yeah then it happens between the second
and the third act it's a bunch of
[ __ ] that doesn't work and you go
yeah you're right it is but like when he
went to the next level of the detail of
what's wrong with it it's kind of like
someone going like that jokes not funny
here's how it would be funny nothing
right the first part of your sentence
was all heated I don't need you now to
tell me how to make it funny and that's
what happens I like when you I don't do
them anymore but back when I would be
forced to do test screenings with an
audience you could just sitting there
you'll know you know okay they're bored
during this part it's boring or they're
not laughing it's supposed to be funny I
don't now need that kid to get up and
explain to the studio how to save the
picture because he watched a movie once
so that the process is like half good
and half insanity
[Applause]